any pair of points can be connected by a
line segment that's right connect two
pairs of black points in a way that
creates two parallel line segments so
let's see if we can do that so I could
create one segment that connects these
this point to this point and then
another one that connects this point to
this point and they look pretty parallel
in fact I think this is the right answer
if we did it another way if we had
connected that point to that point if we
connected that point to that point and
this point to this point then it
wouldn't look so parallel these clearly
if they were to keep these were to keep
going they would intersect at some point
so let me set it back up the way I did
it the first time let me make these two
points let me make these two points
parallel and these are line segments
because they have two endpoints they
each have two endpoints and they
continue forever well they don't
continue forever they continue forever
in no directions in 0 directions if it
was array it would continue forever in
one direction if it's a line it
continues forever past both of these
points in fact it wouldn't have
endpoints they would just continue
forever in both of these both of these
directions let's do one more
drag the Ray so it has an endpoint at a
so we want to make its endpoint a day
where the Ray terminates and goes
through one of the other black points
the Ray should also be parallel to the
pink line so have two options I could
make it go through this black point
there's clearly not parallel in fact it
looks perpendicular here so let's may
try to make it go through this point
well yes when I do that it does indeed
look like my Ray is parallel to the pink
line and this is array because it has
one endpoint this is where the reiter
Minh eighths it's an endpoint it
literally ends there and it continues
forever in one direction in this case
the direction is to the right it
continues forever to the right so it
continues forever in one continues
forever in one direction